how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and if
you're here you probably watched hawkeye
episode 5. and if you didn't i'm gonna
go ahead and give you a spoiler warning
because i want to jump right into this
kingpin is finally in the mcu and the
best part is it's vinnie d it's vincent
d'onofrio he is back reprising his role
as kingpin now right off the bat i don't
think this is going to be the same
character from the netflix series yes
it's kingpin yes it's d'onofrio but i
doubt they're keeping the stories from
the netflix series in the mcu those
aren't canon it seemed like kevin feige
pretty much made that clear so they're
basically going to reboot the character
but keep the same actor that played him
and kevin feige recently mentioned this
about daredevil he said that if and when
daredevil does come to the mcu matt
murdock charlie cox would indeed be
playing him and since he said that and
since kingpin is now in the mcu and we
are getting an echo series i'm assuming
daredevil is not too far behind so be
excited about that as well but let's
break down this ending and what exactly
is going on in the hawkeye series and
what we can expect from the finale next
week and also my giveaway is still going
on we've chosen about 12 winners so far
still a ton of stuff to give away so be
sure to subscribe and check the pin
comment and description for your ways to
enter now as myself and many of you
pretty much everybody suspected eleanor
is indeed not exactly good to start off
she has clearly framed jack
unfortunately in the beginning of the
show jack was really made to kind of
appear like a villain however they were
pretty obvious and in your face about it
which usually means it's a distraction
from what's actually going on which we
have now found out eleanor is actually
working for kingpin or with him and just
as i suspected from the last episode
jack has no idea about sloane as he
stated in this episode he's never heard
of that company and he makes a joke even
though it is actually very serious
stating that he's never worked a day in
his life because he was kind of born
into money now the only reason this
happens is because kate tells her mother
that her and hawkeye figured this out so
eleanor who is most likely madam mask
which we'll talk about in a bit knows
that hawkeye is going to be gunning for
her so what does she do she goes ahead
and calls the cops on jack who
unfortunately is indeed a patsy like i
talked about in my last breakdown and is
simply a person who is kind of loveblind
right now with eleanor so unfortunately
he takes the fall for eleanor and he
doesn't know it's eleanor meanwhile
yelena gives kate a visit he goes to her
old apartment where yelena is waiting
for her and they have what yelena calls
a girl's night yelena of course knows
that kate bishop isn't a bad person she
believes in hawkeye but yelena thinks
that hawkeye is bad she believes that he
is responsible for the death of her
sister this is most likely due to val
who was introduced in the falcon and the
winter soldier and in the post-credits
scene of black widow telling yelena that
clint was responsible for the death of
natasha now yelena seems pretty set in
her ways but kate does seemingly
convince her that maybe there is more to
hawkeye than she actually knows maybe
hawkeye actually is a good person who
cared for natasha kate says you need to
do some research looking into who hired
you to take out hawkeye which again
we'll talk about in just a bit but the
final piece to the puzzle of this ending
that you need to know is what happens
with clint and maya clint visits the
avengers shrine where he goes and takes
his earpiece out so he can have silence
and talk to natasha you can tell that
her death still haunts him as he tried
himself to be the one that would be
sacrificed for the soul stone but in the
end it was her and he still is haunted
by it but the last thing he does before
he leaves the shrine is apologize to her
and in this scene with maya and clint it
becomes very clear what he is
apologizing for he is apologizing for
becoming ronin again he was ronin during
the five-year gap where he went on a
killing spree spring granted he was
killing bad people but a killing spring
nonetheless but natasha came and found
him and pulled him out of it he was
ronin no more because of her so he
apologizes to her for becoming ronin
again now as ronan he visits maya and he
takes out everybody so it's just her and
him and here's where he drops a really
big bomb on maya now after defeating her
he shows his face to her so she realizes
that it's hawkeye it's the avenger and
he quickly says that if you come after
me again or my family it'll be the last
thing you do obviously because he'll
kill her then he says that you and i
we're the same she says no you are a
monster speaking of what he did as ronan
specifically about him killing her dad
however i'm still not so sure he did
which i'll talk about clinton says we're
both weapons but when we're filled with
rage we're blind and here's where we
kind of start to see the story all come
together clinton says that this rage
makes you blind which means you can be
used and manipulated and this is where
clint drops the bomb he says i was there
that night tipped off by an informant
who works for your boss he says your
boss wanted your father dead now he's
using you now of course maya doesn't
believe him or she doesn't want to
believe him but now it's all actually
lining up with the comic storyline
pretty accurately and this is where
we'll connect everything maya meets back
up with qazi and asks him a very
important question why wasn't he there
that night when everybody else is he
doesn't really have an answer he says i
don't know i just didn't get the call
but my theory is that he might have been
dressed up as ronan now i acknowledge
this could be wrong hawkeye was in a
rough time and he was taking out bad
people and technically the tracksuit
mafia are bad people so hawkeye still
could very well be the person that
killed maya's father but where was kazi
now it could be that kingpin just didn't
want him there so he wouldn't die that
of course makes sense but i'm wondering
if qazi is the one who killed maya's
father in the comics he is very very
ruthless and he's kind of the main one
that hawkeye fights against which isn't
really what we're seeing here but of
course we'll wait and see but hawkeye
actually does convince maya that
something's going on which is why she
asked qazi where he was and based off of
how she leaves she clearly understands
that things aren't as they seem now her
boss is obviously kingpin this is
revealed when elena sends kate bishop a
text message she actually took her
advice and tracked down who hired her
and as it turns out it was eleanor
bishop kate's mother so here's what
happened and this is kind of the big
picture in the photo that elena sends we
see eleanor with kingpin hawkeye
confirms that's who i was worried about
he was worried about him because
obviously he has dealt with him in the
past obviously ronan has dealt with him
and took out a lot of the tracksuit
mafia now eleanor is clearly one of the
bad guys and she is most likely madame
mask who works with kingpin in the
comics kingpin is in charge of the
tracksuit mafia he is their boss and
he's qazi's boss this is straight from
the comics as well kingpin employs the
tracksuit mafia he employs qazi and he
also looks after ekko after her father
dies in the comics but in the comics
kingpin is actually the one that kills
her father now eventually she figures
this out with the help of matt murdock
aka daredevil obviously that part's not
going to be the same here hawkeye is
really the one that is showing her that
her boss kingpin is actually a bad guy
and it looks like he is responsible for
her father's death so everything is
really coming together here now eleanor
clearly realized that hawkeye was going
to be a problem because hawkeye and her
daughter kate were looking into some
things that they shouldn't be looking
into like the sloan company that's under
jack's name that does money laundering
for the tracksuit mafia which kingpin is
in charge of so eleanor calls kingpin
and what do they decide to do hire a
black widow assassin to take out hawkeye
before hawkeye gets in the middle of all
of their business now it's unclear on
whether or not kingpin knows that
hawkeye is ronin it's irrelevant because
kingpin would want to kill hawkeye for
meddling anyways and maybe he even likes
ronin he said he was tipped off by an
informant and he said that your boss
wanted your dad dead so was the
informant the boss kingpin or was the
informant quasi that's gonna be what's
revealed in the final episode now keep
in mind that we're going to be going
into the echo series and kingpin will
indeed be in the echo series and
reportedly daredevil will be as well so
there are some things that aren't going
to be really wrapped up here but
hopefully they have a really really good
ending i'm worried that there actually
is so much to wrap up that we're gonna
be left on a cliffhanger for some but
pretty much that's what's going on
eleanor and kingpin are working together
they control the tracksuit mafia eleanor
is probably mad at mask they hired a
black widow assassin to kill hawkeye
because hawkeye is meddling val when she
gave elena the job lied to her and told
her that hawkeye was responsible for her
sister's death which isn't completely
untrue but it is a wide stretch of the
truth and yelena will most likely
realize this and eventually help hawkeye
and kate now the only thing that we
really don't know about yet is the watch
who does the rolex belong to does it
belong to laura and who is she is she
mockingbird a former agent of shield did
she work for a kingpin before we don't
know that yet but of course that should
be revealed in next week's episode but
we'll have to wait and see in the
meantime let me know what you thought
about this episode of hawkeye rate it 1
out of 10 down below and of course don't
forget to like the video if you enjoyed
it don't forget to subscribe for more
marvel content and as always you can
follow me on instagram and twitter for
live updates and of course thank you all
so much for watching woof
you